(energetic music)
- I've gone to the point
where I will go through an entire day
of just having the little
bit of garnish on my food
and count that as my
vegetable for the day.
- Well, I've been Vegan for a year.
Some of you might think, oh
so she must be really healthy
and eat a lot of vegetables, but I don't.
- I've been feeling
really lethargic lately.
I'm hoping that eating
enough fresh vegetables
might change that.
- For women, 19 to 30, should
have one and a half cups
of dark green vegetables.
- Five point five cups of
red and orange vegetables.
- And five cups of starch vegetables.
- I could do that.
Although, hang on.
How much is a cup?
I'm not for sure.
That seems like quite a lot
now I'm thinking about it.
- I have to eat two cups
of dark green vegetables,
six cups of red-green vegetables,
six cups of starch vegetables.
I feel like I'm just gonna
poop a lot this week.
- [Megan] I don't know where to start
'cause I don't know what
to do with any of them.
- I'm realizing I don't really
know how much is a serving
of certain foods.
- Yay cheese.
- [Ray] So today for
lunch, I had this pizza,
but I usually don't order a
side salad, but today I did.
- I took out my Vegan
Cookbook for Beginners
and there's no whole category
for cooking vegetables.
They're like, bitch
you should know by now.
- So, I'm at brunch and
originally I was gonna get
The Hangover Killer Scramble,
but since I'm making an effort,
I'm getting the Angeleno
Veggie two point O.
It actually looks really good.
I'm pretty sure this cuts
for like two servings
at the least.
- [Chloe] Okay, well I guess
I'll just do a cup of peas
which means I need another
cup and a half of vegetables
by the end of the day, which
seems like a freakin' lot.
- I've realized something horrible.
Everything is measured and cut
for my rosemary roasted vegetables,
and I look at my spice rack
and I have no rosemary.
- So I'm cooking a stir-fry
and I am gonna put red pepper in it,
but I just feel like most of
what I eat is like the leafy greens.
How many vegetables are there
that are really red and orange?
That's like so specific.
- [Ray] Having fun, and this lettuce leaf.
That's gonna be wrapped in this.
I don't even know if this
counts as a complete serving?
(bell ringing)
- I got my salad from Ralph's,
and I'm gonna add some more leafy greens
'cause I can never have too many of them.
I gotta get through this now
so I can forget about
for the rest of the day
which is not how you're suppose to do it.
- My veges look sort of wilted?
I couldn't do you guys.
I couldn't finish them.
Oh my god, they're so dry.
- So I'm pretty impressed with myself
because last night I
actually meal prepped.
Look at this!
- Joey's judging my salad.
- You know tomatoes are
technically a fruit, right?
- We can't be friends.
- How do you feel about the idea of eating
that many vegetables in a week?
- There's gonna be a lot of farts.
- I ate more than enough yesterday.
- Oh.
- Did you fart?
- No I didn't fart. (laughing)
- Okay, I just wanna know.
- So, I made noodles but
then I made this salad.
I am attracted to the salad, you know.
I really feel like this challenge
has sort of changed my ways.
- After this whole week,
I've been very regular.
- I definitely think in the long run
it would absolutely help
me with energy levels
and stuff like that.
I definitely want to carry on with this
and do this as a lifestyle.
I don't hate vegetables.
I've never hated vegetables.
I actually don't like fruit very much.
(energetic music)